abone ol
[Alkış]
bu video
abone ol
o mavi dediğimiz zaman aklımıza ilk
gelen bilgilerden biri Denizli
Aslında o
Sen ne yapıyorsun abisi düzine
yansıyarak
bu gün bitirdiğimiz getirdi
görmesini sağla
neden bir bardak Daha büyükleri vermek
suları yani göreceğiniz mavi ekliyoruz
o mavi Şimdi ne yapmam lazım
abone ol
bu
hastalığını
baktınız
hapsediyor neden oldu Turkuaz renkler
kırmızı geçirilebilir
bu
Çanakkale'de bundan bir görüldüğü gibi
belli zamanlarda tahmin edilmektedir
bunun
üzerine olduğu beslenirlerdi
Bunun dışında da alanı kapalı açık
olması da aşırı yavşağı sonucunda ya da
eğer varsa o
var
[Müzik]
bunun dışında
Ne yazdın polardan da
de İstanbul'a gitmiş ondan olarak kadar
hiç yoktur bu suyu sistemlerde
yaşamlarını sürdürürler
abone ol
bu ne kadar yani burada Mavi Ay
[Müzik]
abone ol bu
işte tekrar bile
insan sağlığı insan
Evet hop onu bırak artık mektup
O ne
3D
abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
dişleri kendi içinde ve
dışında insanlık için önemli Olması
televizyonda diyecek olur
O her çağda
ha
ha kaynağı olmuştur
Evet şimdi buldum düşünür geleceklerinin
yaşadığınız burada yüzlerce tur yaşıyor
Hatta bunu bir kız
vardı o
[Müzik]
abone ol
Allah
rahim sağlığınızı Borçlu olduğumuz
Fiat bayi parasal karşılığı değil
İşte
bu yüzden Burak kimdir gözlük zenginiz
gelecek mi
yapabileceğim
olmanın diye
bir
ara sor dedi gökçalık yeni bozduğuna
Assos küçük bir köye mi
mı değiştirdin son bölüm yüksek olduğu
yani burada e-postanı Ala sağlıklı Bu
mağara ve
bu
Şurada da
konusundaki
Gelibolu projeye göre gökyüzündeki
tarihi doğal farkının önemi topluluk
ve
sanayileşme ilahileri Olmalı Olmalı bu
kitabımızın gerekti ama biraz enerji
lazım
Bu
insanlık her zaman ileriye doğru
gitmiştim Ancak bu Bilal Emin nasıl
olmalı
aynı birlikte öğrenelim
bu paylaşayım başladı bu
Ben söyledim
bir gün yanına mutluluk ve çevre demek
ki
ve en kayıt daha büyük olayı
şu Antep in aynı mı
var yani karşı Onu sonra
ilave mi artık nasıl sürülür değil
bir
dönüş yap
bu dünyada denizlerin ölmeyen
kahramanlarına
ondan bahsetmek istiyorum
o top
sıkıntıyla
mikroskobik canlı
ve en önemli tozalti ilgili dışı mı
en
güçlü ve karbon büyük olanı yani
anlayacağın resimleri oksijen öğretmen
kaynaklı kaynaklı
[Müzik]
mi
Evet o
abone ol Yok
canım 61
O ne be
Bu
araştırma
oksijen daha fazlasını
bu
aralar tatil oldu mu
çok az önce bir şey dedim gözlükler
kendiliğinden bahsetti
ne kadar sağlıklı olduğunu gösteriyor
İnsan vücudunda
ne kadar
ve gidersin her şey o
abone ol
13 çişli ne kadar fazla
O ne la zaten
dışarıdan gelecek
1980ler Karadeniz daha
abone ol
bu İbrahim
[Müzik]
eğlence taşınmış
bu ve bu yıllardı sözlerindeki bütün
Partisi topları çekmesine neden olur 4'ü
[Müzik]
abone ol
çok daha önemli Böylece
müzik ile ilgili
abone ol
o yüzünü göster astronot olarak
tanımlayabiliriz
bu gizli Boğazı popo bileşikler nedir bu
daha fazla
kullandınız
bunu nasıl yaptık
[Müzik]
bunun yanında
bu
ormansızlaşma
Teşekkür ederim E bunu
denize taşması
beni takip aldı la la Sonra bir tanesi
başım hediyesi dış anlamlısı
Ben yazdım başa nereden almışlar
ama
yarın ortamdaki ölüyorsun ne yapacağız
parçaları insan kaynakları etler giriş
Elif Bu gördüğünüz tabakaları oluşturduk
suyun
[Müzik]
üstünde ama
var bunun için fotoğraf boyu
İstanbul tekrar gidiyorum
da
buza nasılmış son Ne oldu kaldırmadan mı
[Müzik]
abone ol
mi Evet Bugün sizlerle taşıtı diğer
önemli istersin başında da
bulaşıcı Aslı bir paleni riskini
arttırması geliyor
bir
tane yeni yaşam alanları yani
[Müzik]
Bu
bir nasıl kullandığınıza
[Müzik]
var Bir tane de
abone ol
ilk defa ezanda Porun içi bu hafta
vardır Bu
o canımı yaktı dışında geçici yapılan
filan dedi hastalıkları görüşürüz annem
dedi ki
[Müzik]
Ben bilmem istediğim daha ettiler
olmadı şimdi yasal kullanmadığı
zamanlarını
375 yılında yılanlarda
görmeye başlıyorsunuz Buyur yüzden
yok oluyor
bu takip eden bir tanem
Ne
oldu ki
Ben
7 yıl türlü
geliyor
sadece patatesli
hala devam etmiş kalkıyorsun
O
benim eski
değişiyor
bırak ya
bu günümüzde hem de türleri
insanlar çok daha fazla bu işlerin
altında Çünkü değişmeye başladı
çok teşekkür et yiyorlar
aşırı yağışlar en yüksek sıcaklık
ortalamaları
Allah Rabbim büyük Fırtınalar bunun
içinde buradan çevre şartları bu Denizli
daha yeni siyah lan o
ve bütün bu kanser testi yaptırdım
en büyük doğal ne yaptın bu tatlının
birini gerçekten ödeyeceksiniz takip
edeceksiniz yani kur'an-ı
UV
Vay sadece romantik değilsin
ben onu araştırarak anlayarak biri
olabilir mi
O çok
sıkıntı var ama bunların ötesinde her
şeyden önemlisi başım
abone ol
[Müzik]
[Alkış]